Welcome back.
We're now in the final
test, test eight.
And we'll start in Section
2, problem one.
The total cost of three equally
priced mechanical
pencils is $4.50.
If the cost per pencil is
increased by $0.50, how much
will five of these
pencils cost?
So three pencils, three times
the cost of the pencil is
equal to $4.50.
So pencil is equal to
$4.50 divided by 3.
Just divide both sides
of that equation by 3
and that equals $1.50.
Then they say the cost per
pencil is increased by $0.50.
So we're going to go from $1.50
plus $0.50, so that'll
get us to $2,00 per pencil.
How much will five of these
pencils cost at the new rate?
So it's $2.00 per pencil, times
5, and that's $10.00.
And that's choice E.
Problem two.
OK, the table above represents
a relationship
between x and y.
So x can be-- x and y,
so it's 1, 2, 3, 4.
And then y, when x is
1, is 3, 7, 11, 15.
Which of the following linear
equations describes the
relationship?
So let's see if we can think of
something here on our own.
Let's see, this looks like--
well, I don't know how you
would get to 4 times-- let's see
the choices, actually, see
which ones work.
So A is y is equal
to x plus 1.
Try this out, x plus 1.
1 plus 1 is 2, so that's
not right.
They've got 3 here.
So that fails.
B, y is equal to x plus 4.
When x is 1-- if it was x plus
4, then this would be 5.
But this is 3, so that's
not right.
Choice C, y is equal to 3x.
That works here, right? x
is 1, y is 3 times 1.
But it fails here, because
when x is 2, then
this should be 6.
But it's 7, so this
isn't right.
These are all wrong.
Choice D, y is equal to 4x.
Well, that fails on
this first one.
When x is 1, if it was
4x, this would be 4.
But it's not, so that fails.
Choice E is probably going
to be our answer.
Let's try.
y is equal to 4x minus 1.
So when x is 1, 4 times
1 is 4 minus 1 is 3.
4 times 2 is 8 minus 1 is 7.
4 times 3 is 12,
minus 1 is 11.
4 times 4 is 16,
minus 1 is 15.
So it works.
Next problem, soon. problem 3.
OK, they drew two circles.
They look tangent
to each other.
One circle looks like that.
Let me see if my skills of
drawing tangent circles, how
good they are.
You got one circle, and
not bad, not bad if I
have to say so myself.
And then they draw a line that
looks like from the center of
one circle to the other.
I'll do it in a different
color.
So we are going from here
roughly to there.
I know it doesn't look like
center to center, but I think
you get the idea.
They're saying this
point here is A.
This point right here is B.
And then this point
right here is C.
In the figure above, the two
circles are tangent at the
point B, and AC is equal to 6,
so this whole distance is
equal to 6, and they're tangent
right here, so these
circles just touch point B.
If the circumference of circle
with center A is twice the
circumference of the circle
with center C, what is the
length of BC?
So we want to know what BC is.
So this circumference is twice
the length of this
circumference.
So what's the formula
for circumference?
Circumference is equal
to 2 pi r, right?
So let's say that this is r.
Let's call this distance r.
What do we know about
this distance?
Let's call that x,
I guess, right?
So if this distance is r, the
radius of the large circle is
r, its circumference is going
to be 2 pi r, right?
So what's the circumference
of the smaller circle?
Well, it's 1/2 of that.
So c/2 is equal to 1/2 of the
big circle circumference is
equal to the circumference of
the smaller circle, which is 2
pi x, right?
Because the radius is x.
But what's c/2?
That's this divided by 2.
So c/2 is the same thing
as this divided
by 2, which is what?
The 2 would just disappear,
so it equals pi r.
You could take both pi's away,
and you get 2x is equal to r,
or x is equal to r/2.
And you really didn't
have to do that.
You could just know that
circumference is directly
proportional to radius, unlike
area, which is proportional to
the square.
So circumference is directly
proportional to radius.
So if this circle has twice
the circumference as this
circle, its radius is also going
to be twice the radius
of this circle.
But that's interesting now.
So now we know that if this is
x, this distance here is x, BC
is x, this distance here is
going to be 2x, right?
It's going to be 2 times
the small radius.
And we know that when you add
all of them together, 2x plus
x, you get the whole length from
AC, A to C, and you so
that equals y.
So you get 3x is equal
to 6 and then you get
x is equal to 2.
And that's our answer,
because we wanted to
know just what x is.
And so the really fast way of
doing this is, if you said,
well, this is going to be
twice-- let's define x as this
small radius.
And if this circle has twice the
circumference, it's going
to have twice the radius.
So this would be 2x.
And then you could just go
straight to this step without
having to do all of this.
Next problem, problem 4.
OK, they drew a bunch
of points.
Let's see, a lot of
drawing for me.
I'm a little tired.
My goal is to finish these
problems this weekend, and
it's midnight and
past my bedtime.
But I'm hanging in there and
trying to finish all of these.
OK, so let's see, they have
point C, which is up here.
And I don't know if I have
to be accurate with the
coordinates yet.
Point B is roughly here.
Point A is here.
So then you have point E that's
right around here.
And then you have point D,
which is right there.
What are they going to ask us?
Which of the letter points
in the figure above has
coordinates x, y, such that the
absolute value of x minus
the absolute value of
y is equal to 3?
So we could just try out the
points, but they're really
just saying that no matter what
the x and y-- they say it
doesn't matter what
quadrant it is.
We want the difference between
the x and the y to be 3.
So the intuition here is that
the x is going to be larger
than the y, right?
Or the distance that x is away
from the origin is going to be
larger by 3 than the distance
that y is away from the
origin, right?
Because the absolute value of x,
you kind of view it as the
distance x is from the origin,
and absolute value of y is the
distance y is from the origin.
So which ones have a larger
distance x from the origin
than a y from the origin?
Well, it looks like D, right?
D looks further in
this direction.
Let me switch colors.
D is further in this direction
than it is in this direction.
And if we look at the other
choices, B also is like that.
And so let's look at
the coordinates.
Those are my prime
coordinates.
If I actually look at the
graph, B looks like
it's 1, 2, 3, 4.
So this looks like minus
4 and minus 1.
So B looks like minus
4, minus 1.
And actually, that looks
like our answer, right?
Because what's the absolute
value of 4?
That's the absolute value of
minus 4 minus the absolute
value of minus 1.
That equals 4 minus
1, which equals 3.
So that is choice B.
We didn't have to try D.
Next problem.
Actually, I'm coming
up on nine minutes.
So I'll do the next problem
in the next video.
I'll see